[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the new
hogwarts legacy game which was first
announced nine months ago
on september 16th playstation dropped
the trailer on their youtube channel
and to say that the trailer got some
fans excited is certainly an
understatement
with over 22 million views and 616
000 likes i think it's safe to say that
this is a game
that fans want the problem it isn't out
yet
in fact it was just recently pushed back
the trailer which is only two and a half
minutes long
was the first shred of new harry potter
game content that we've had in a very
long time
and it showed us the wizarding world in
a bit of a different light
during a time period predating the
traditional harry potter story
the game which is brought to us by port
key games and avalanche software
takes place 100 plus years before harry
starts attending hogwarts
in the late 1800s creators of the game
have also since released
press releases confirming that the game
is in fact an
open world action role-playing game
which will allow you to
create your own personal witcher wizard
and spec them exactly as you want them
to be
players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
like never before as they live the
unwritten and embark on a dangerous
journey
to uncover a hidden truth of the
wizarding world they will grow their
characters abilities as they master
powerful spells home combat skills and
select companions to help them face off
against
deadly enemies players will also
encounter missions and scenarios
that will pose difficult choices and
determine what they stand for
obviously with nine months to sit on
this trailer fans have amassed quite a
few questions about the game
and in this video i'm going to be
addressing some of these commonly asked
questions
whether it pertains to the gameplay
release date or
storyline first big question when will
hogwarts legacy be released
the answer to that is 2022 originally
the game was meant to come out this year
but as with lots of things harry potter
it was eventually pushed back
the good news is that the next fantastic
beasts also comes out in 2022
so it'll be a big year for harry potter
the next
question is what platforms will hogwarts
legacy be on
according to the official website for
the game it will be available on
lots of different platforms including
playstation 5
playstation 4 playstation 4 pro the xbox
one family devices
including xbox series x and xbox one x
and of course pc the next question is
how does hogwarts legacy fit into the
harry potter wizarding world
the game creators had this to say while
port key games are not direct
adaptations of the books and films
the games are firmly rooted in the harry
potter universe
while remaining true to jk rowling's
original work
portuguese game developers chart new
territory by creating fresh ways for
fans
to immerse themselves in the wizarding
world essentially what that means is
this
they're using rowling's framework and
will be staying true to the wizarding
world that we know
but we'll also be introducing some new
concepts
the official website also mentioned the
following
while hogwarts legacy is not a direct
adaptation of the books and films
the games are anchored in wizarding
world lore avalanche is creating a
unique
gaming experience that is inspired by jk
rowling's wizarding world
in which players will find new and
unexpected locations
characters and story elements a good
follow-up question to that one
is is hogwarts legacy an original story
the story of the game has players
experiencing life as a student
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry like never before
as i live the unwritten and embark on a
dangerous journey to uncover a hidden
truth of the wizarding world
will we see ron hermione and harry in
the game
unfortunately the answer to this is no
as hogwarts legacy
is set in the 1800s before the trio were
born
however i am certainly curious to see
how many easter eggs they fit into the
game
so i'm sure fans would love that is
hogwarts legacy
multiplayer hogwarts legacy is not a
multiplayer game
but it seems as though an mmo is on the
cards
what kind of game is hogwarts legacy
what's the story
hogwarts legacy is an immersive
open-world action role-playing game set
in the 1800s
which puts players at the center of
their own adventure
players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
as they embark on a dangerous journey
they will grow their magical abilities
by mastering spells
brewing potions and taming fantastic
beasts
how do you play hogwarts legacy hogwarts
legacy is filled with immersive magic
putting players at the center of their
adventure to become the witch or wizard
they choose to be
they will grow their characters
abilities as they master powerful spells
hone combat skills and select companions
to help them face off against deadly
enemies
players will also encounter missions and
scenarios that will pose difficult
choices
and determine what they stand for can
players choose and
switch their hogwarts house in hogwarts
legacy
yes players will be able to choose their
hogwarts house
at the start of hogwarts legacy where
does the game take place
at this time we know that the game will
take place in the hogwarts castle
forbidden forest and hogsmeade village
what is
jk rowling's involvement with the game
is this a new story from jk rowling
jk rowling is not directly involved in
the creation of the game
but her body of writing is being used as
the foundation for the game
the game will not influence existing
harry potter canon at all
who is developing the game port key
games from
warner bros games is the games label
dedicated to creating
new wizarding world mobile and video
game experiences
that place the player the center of
their own adventure
inspired by jk rowling's original
stories portkey games offers players the
opportunity to make their own narrative
choices
and engage with the wizarding world
setting to discover new
and unique experiences the label was
created
to bring gamers and fans new gaming
experiences
that allow them to delve into the
wizarding world in immersive ways
where they can create their own magical
stories
will dumbledore be in hogwarts legacy
the game takes place in the late 1800s
which technically means that since we're
going to be attending hogwarts
we should see some familiar faces
there's also one man in particular that
i'm hoping to see
that was quite important in the harry
potter franchise
albus dumbledore ever heard of him
dumbledore was born in the year 1881
and he started attending hogwarts in the
year 1892
provided that the game takes place in
the late 1800s
i'm going to assume this will also cover
the 1880s and 1890s
which means that yes there's a chance
we'll see young dumbledore
who will be the bad guy in hogwarts
legacy this hasn't yet been revealed
but i do have a few theories my first
theory is that it was a dark wizard
by the name of a chrysdis i've mentioned
a christus in my past videos
but in case you don't know about him
here's a recap basically he's a dark
wizard
who was taught to have created the
dementors very little is known about him
other than the fact that he was alive
during the 15th century
and that he was evil my next theory is
that it was in fact
one of the previous owners of the elder
wand the elder wand is the most powerful
one
in existence and throughout its history
it certainly fell into the wrong hands
on more than one occasion
with all sorts of dark wizards using it
for evil
the wand would pass hands quite
frequently with one evil wizard besting
another
every few decades a few wizards come to
mind that could have possessed the wand
during the game's time period
the first wizard that comes to mind is
barnabas deveral
a wizard who in the early to mid 18th
century
began using the wand for evil earning
himself quite the reputation
and that's it for this video are you
guys excited for this game
i know i am comment down below if you'll
be playing
also feel free to ask any questions i
perhaps didn't cover
and i'll try my best to answer until
next time
you're a wizard lowry
you